Okay.
Brian Post St Ladies and gentlemen just got done doing the podcast.
You're hilarious.
As always.
Thanks buddy.
Brian is one of those dudes that I've known for about probably 15 years or
something like that.
But I've been down here since.
This is the first time we ever really sat down and were like a serious
conversation for sure.
But we talked when we worked together show.
But yeah,
nothing like that.
Like the two hours.
That was fun man.
It was cool.
Brian is no longer in the pot club.
You folks,
I'll be back.
We caught him three months completely sober cause that's gotta be a weird thing
to be like the POC community.
He was one of those guys,
one of them.
I'm worth the metal community until somebody pointed out to me and I was like,
yeah,
you're right.
Yeah.
But uh,
yeah,
definitely don't do that many pot jokes,
but it all kind of came from a plot place.
I mean,
most of those jokes were written while I was high.
And the thing,
the important thing is that he's the one that indoctrinated duct Bateson who's
probably the biggest pothead comedian.
I mean nobody's connected more to pot as a comic than duck.
It's like teaching karyotype about props like yes,
exactly.
But it's worse.
These two things together and make fun of that.
I did that.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't say worse,
but I mean it's bigger because carrot tops not spreading props all across the
country and getting other people to do props.
So that's done for that movie.
Super High.
Me.
How many people got started smoking weed because of that movie?
That a lot.
Yeah,
I've been a lot of people looked at that and go,
what the fuck man?
He looks fine.
Print would bring up all over here.
So this is if you,
if you're upset and Doug done some monsters I guess.
Yeah,
I bet you did dude.
You spawned it.
Brian Post saying,
ladies and gentlemen,
thanks for being on the podcast.
Thanks.
Awesome.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Looks like that city and salt city.
What's the,
all this salt on the ground is actually what I get out of the tub.
The tank rather,
and it's also because a,
at one point in time,
back in the past I had a rupture in the lining and the saltwater leaked out and
got over the floor and we had a wine and cleaning it out and doing a bunch of
different things to fix it.
New Tank from folate lab,
float lab technology and so this all this shit on the ground.
It's all just songs,
Yolanda and all that.
Now it's kind of boring.
Our cane,
Neil Brennan,
thank you very much for being on the Poncho,
man.
Pleasure was all mine and get you into the isolation.
It's in Venice.
I'm going to call him for you.
It'd be an awesome thing for you to sit and think of ideas.
There's no environment like that on the planet where you don't feel your body
disconnect from your body and you're all inside your head.
It's amazing.
Pretty close to,
I'm just walking around,
I'm so in my head,
but I,
I'm a,
I'm a human isolation.
Well in your head,
in your head there would be no,
I'm fucking here.
When does it kick in?
Well,
it depends on how relaxed you know,
how much you can let go.
It takes a while to get comfortable with the experience cause it's so weird.
I feel like I would cry.
Does that make sense?
You might cry.
Have you ever cried?
Not In there,
but in real life yet.
You have several times.
Wow.
Oh no more than that.
No person.
No,
I didn't cry your nap.
No.
It takes up more than a cartoon to get me to cry.
Brown.
A little bit of tears.
Excuse me.
First of all,
it takes three d and live action.
I kind of titanic like a motherfucker should really?
Wow.
That's twice I cried cause I paid $7 for that piece of like,
did you really like titanic?
Do you know what I liked about it when they were,
uh,
they did the flyover of the ship.
When you look at the people walking and it's cause it's old CGI,
they like still robotic.
Yeah.
I enjoy that about it.
That's my favorite part of titanic.
When everything looks fake like it.
I thought it was a dumb move and I liked it.
I liked it.
I like the Capri.
I would like it if it was just the thing crashing into the water because the
special effects were awesome.
Other than that,
no.
You didn't like when he stenciled her,
I would.
It probably,
that would have been that.
Right,
right.
And I liked that she was naked and still like that was nice that you can think
it.
That's what an awful double standard the MPA has.
Is that like she was tasteful naked right now,
but she's still naked.
I don't give a fuck.
I still saw a woman's netball.
Did you see her nipple?
Yeah.
I think I even remember whatever happened.
That chick,
she turned into a meet Bob Wright and she,
no,
she's all right.
She got big.
She didn't,
she got you.
That's good.
Actually.
Probably smaller than she was then Barilla.
Yeah.
Didn't she go meet bomb for a little while though?
The Internet will agree with me.
Christina Aguilera meet bomb.
Wait,
if you say anything negative about a lady,
the Internet will agree.
Right,
meatball or
Kirstie alley and what a hog.
Right.
Whenever you ever look at her.
When she was on cheers,
she was so hot.
Shit.
Aye.
The her first episode of chairs when I thought I was like,
damn,
like he's kind of big.
She was a little big from it.
He or she was wearing leather pants.
I remember she was like purple leather pants and it's one of those acids where
you just go,
I don't,
I think that's you don't like,
it's too big for me.
Uh,
I like a size three.
I mean not that is,
I don't need this.
That's how manly I am.
I don't know.
I just made that up,
but uh,
I don't like it.
I like a nice ass.
Got a great story about Mark Coleman.
He was in the UFC heavyweight champion or hanging out once in a strip club.
We had this girl said,
I was laughing.
He goes,
she's only about 90 pounds.
And then he goes and puts,
it got to be tight.
That's how he was.
He was breaking it down.
She don't know nothing about so you can't have a loose,
but say at that at that way class.
He figured and he's a gorilla.
Just got tagged or
looking at rabbit.
Yeah,
they're all over the place out here.
Coyotes,
coyotes at night amount nine killed someone's dog out here even a couple of
years ago and when people are still talking about it.
Can I have your buddy?
We're here live with monster brawny monster vine.
Just got to in the pot.
Got done doing the podcast for the first time.
That was cool.
That was fun.
Thanks for having me.
Thanks a lot of fun.
It was great.
It was interesting.
We got to talk all kinds of shit.
International politics.
We went deep deep to the Middle East by the way.
Iranians not have her ups.
Okay.
Remember that important shit.
I don't like to be called Arabs.
Yeah man,
that's very important.
I'll track you down and cut you.
And Moz has a podcast with her other pal al magical that's been on the podcast
several times.
And Chris Spencer,
it's called [inaudible] minivan men.
And you go to a minivan,
men.com and you can check that out and people can catch you on Mazda brawny.com
right.
I'm everywhere,
man.
Find ways forever.
Each other man,
boy.
But several years I uh,
Joe,
I remember when I first started the comedy store,
Joe was just,
you,
the,
you were the man killing it and now you're killing it here and you know,
um,
the comedy store was a fun place back in the day.
It was,
it's my cuts can't go back.
I first remembered Mazda's name all the time because every time you saw him you
would always sing his song.
Joe,
I don't know why man.
I think Joey Diaz,
Diaz Joey would come in during my sets in the middle of my son.
Just start singing.
I would cut.
I was just,
Oh,
it's mine.
When Joey stopped coming to the comedy store,
that's one of the things that killed it.
She always stopped coming six months before the I got kicked out of their nose.
When he stopped coming here,
I was like,
God,
like what is right?
He just fucking hated them.
Yeah.
It would just go by the fuck are we doing coming to this fucking shit or get
angry at you.
Come down and store and get the fuck out of here.
That fucking place.
Yeah.
It was a magical time there.
Man flew off the wall the other day.
They have head shots on all the walls and the other day it just,
I guess flew off and cracking the pieces.
Right.
We went through a magical era.
There's an era of us and you and me and Ari and Brody and trip to Tripoli.
There's an error that we went through those those years of like the early two
thousands yeah,
those a fun era and a lot of good comics came out of there.
It was a good time for comedy there and it was a good,
there was some nights,
man,
we have like some Friday nights,
Saturday nights there was packed and it was fun.
Look at the lineup and it was you and Aaron k there and truthfully in me and one
after the other,
and Ari and Joey.
It was like,
man,
those were fun times.
Those were fun times.
That place.
Yeah,
I guess there's a new wave of good guys there.
Now keep hearing.
Yeah,
no,
it's so it goes,
that's how it goes.
Baby Song calls out in the wild world of stand up comics roster.
[inaudible] gentlemen,
Here's ladies and gentlemen and his friend Jr Monday,
junior Samson from London,
who we just met today.
Fabulous guest in the podcast.
And he broke,
broke the jinx.
Sir,
you didn't know about the jinx before you got here,
but we've had the chinks of having two guys on.
So it's four people in the podcast and everybody talks over everybody and we'd
have to disaster and twice it happened accidentally.
Twice.
One Guy,
one time a guy brought his girlfriend.
We know he's doing his girlfriend.
His girlfriend started talking.
None time.
A guy brought a a ride and this ride happened to be a comic.
So he said,
well,
sit in and it became a disaster.
But you sir,
we're not a disaster.
Thank you very much.
Good talking to you.
It worked out well,
Russell.
You're the fucking man.
It's almost you're too young fellow.
I left you a book and a DVD.
You can ignore them as much.
I'm going to read your book,
man.
I'm going to find out about your childhood.
I want to find out what makes Russell Tech.
You'll find out it's all in there.
It's all in there.
Did you really write it?
I heard this rumor that your brother,
my brother wrote it.
It's written in the front of my brother wrote it.
It won't take long drives and then we would Hebrew record,
but we just talk and then he would just text whatever I said.
Oh,
that's smart.
And really funny because in the opening thing here,
she family,
he was lifting you to do interview.
Uh,
thank my brother for writing this because if I wrote written it would have been
a flyer.
I'm actually writing my book and it's a lot of God damn work.
There's a lot of work to sit there in front of that and it was like my bro,
who knows me better than my brother.
They were brother,
sister.
She wouldn't do a good job.
One of our heads,
no brother
inside wonder buy your child.
Well,
you've got to be brothers.
I have to know everything.
What's your middle name?
James.
Nice.
Dominic.
Dominic Russell.
And you're the Italian.
I got the fucking Italian middle name.
Ridiculous.
How'd you get down the middle man?
A Godfather?
Yeah,
100% Indian.
Do you have other shit in you?
Both my parents are from India,
but we're kind of mixed with the British.
The British interest says they were fucking us for 400 years.
Nice.
And he was the richest country in the world.
Tell the British got there until when?
When the British get there.
But in the 16 hundreds Jesus Christ even apologizing blink of an eye as far as
the universe goes.
So 400 years ago you guys were dominant.
Spice was one of the richest countries in the world.
He had all the spices,
spices and gold and jewels that fun.
That's what when Columbus came to America,
that dumb fuck.
Dot.
He landed in India.
They were trying to do,
I do a joke about that.
Why do they,
when they call natives Indians,
because I fucking retard was looking for my people.
I said,
what are you doing on Columbus Day?
Drive around until you don't know where the fuck you are.
Anyway,
it's true.
I mean you had to talk about the GPS stuff.
It's Columbus Day,
how bad navigation was and how little they knew about what was out there in the
world.
They thought they were going to drop off the edge of the earth.
They thought that they can get to the point there was in the ocean,
wouldn't have a drop off and that would be,
they fucking took a chance and they got all the way to America,
you know,
and thought they were in India,
like there were so off.
They weren't even really an American.
They were in The Bahamas.
Right then they went to The Bahamas was first.
Yeah,
the somewhere and then eventually slowly figuring out a way to poison the entire
country.
It's true.
Here we are,
California,
2011 live in like a doctor that's meant,
just bought a fucking Rolls Royce convertible.
It was,
he used Oh nine oh nine 7,000 miles on it.
That's a good move.
How's your coating?
It's still got it,
got rid of it.
Really sold it.
Who bought it?
What else killed him?
Did I tell you a story?
I was driving it on the highway.
It was going 70 80 miles an hour.
Get home in my driveway.
I pull into my driveway and I hear cut and my car liens,
so I get out and the suspension has detached itself from the frame and the wheel
is stuck in bent into the front fender and I'm like,
that could have happened 10 minutes ago when I was in a highway that would be
dead,
so I got it all fixed.
I got everything repaired and I got the shifts pension redone.
No,
no chip just designed it.
Chip Foose just designed it and a guy named Troy Japan.
Yay.
Built it.
Then I got a guy out here,
Steve Stroke.
He fixed everything.
Did read to the suspension.
I sold it.
Got a Porsche gt three what?
What?
What does that it?
It's in the garage fool,
so I'll show him.
See you.
Yeah.
[inaudible].